pilots roll sounds like you got this
yeah sweaty hands I'm the most nervous
about this one okay bring in the super
stardestroyer
at hand oh you did I have Jake hand it
to you like a spear please hold it like
a spear but if you can change your grip
by yourself okay stop
hands are I mean it's really there's no
fool there's no hand hold on this and my
hands are sweaty yeah that's why I
wanted you to spear it I can't okay it
will fall if I do that okay I can do it
like this okay
you ready Alex great ready next
go-around roll action I think I look
good think you nailed it
alright spring him down hands are
drenched sweat that's a win
the guys come at the Bueller is
wait about that
it's like it's perfect as you can see in
front here the tip a little bit bad
I'm going straight down onto the steel
plate Jesus Christ he really did it
to spear man that's a death little
something